(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] It is the
ultimate eternal tribute
to your first love, your mom.
The I love mom heart
tattoo, iconic and beloved.
The history of the mom-centric tribute
dates back to the 1700s,
when sailors were at the
forefront of tattoo culture.
Picture this: you're staring
down a long stint at sea,
possibly to never return home.
These said sailors often wanted to keep
their loved ones close,
and what could be any loser
than a heart on your arm?
This heart could symbolize
the heart of a girlfriend,
a wife, or mom.
It is even said that mom can
symbolize a love of country,
the motherland, if you will.
But nothing says I love mom like this guy,
Norman Collins, AKA Sailor Jerry.
Sailor Jerry is the man who popularized
and polarized the I love mom
tattoo, amongst many others.
Nowadays, I love mom tattoos
are as popular as ever
amongst those in the
service and civilians.
Though the imagery has changed a bit,
the heartfelt sentiment remains the same.
We love you mom.